if it's really the case that sex workers
work then what is the problem with being
asked by your boss to give him a [ __ ]
it's work it's just a service it's like
being asked to do over time or make a
coffee no one actually thinks that it's
just like making a coffee
louise perry welcome to the show thank
you so much for having me
given your political background
how does it feel to have ben shapiro
quote tweeting your work
i
i didn't know he had did you not see
this no let me tell you so there is a
tweet that uh someone put out a couple
of days ago
explaining about how
don't kink shame the
naked men doing parades in front of
children and twerking in front of cops
and that was one photo which was a news
story and the other photo was the
chapter list from your book
[Laughter]
which said things like men and women are
different and uh loveless sex is not
empowering and it said um
uh
people of the west choose your future
something like that
oh wow okay
that yeah okay that that that explains
things i haven't noticed i have quite
like a heavy notification filter on on
twitter so i don't always see
everything
um the contents page though completely
blew up like
three months ago
long before the book was published they
just the publisher just put up online
the cover the title the fact that
kathleen stock wrote the forward because
she's got a kind of existing reputation
among
among
her haters my haters and the contents
page and that was enough to have like a
several day twitter storm why do you
think those statements
i mean i guess because
i mean i did i did write the chapters
with the knowledge that they're like
they're simultaneously obvious
and also incredibly provocative
which was which was like precisely my
intention because just some because some
people read it i mean some people read
the whole book
but some people read the chapter titles
in particular and they're like yeah
and other people read them as like
fascists basically
i mean like like like so politically
outrageous i mean i'd say that the
response to the book so far
has only been out for a couple of weeks
in the uk and not yet in the states is
um like 80 really positive and 20
complete outrage
and not very much in the middle
i think what do you think is going to
happen when it comes out in america
it's a good question i mean the the like
the culture war is more intense in
america in every way it's so similar i
think to what we have here i mean
actually i think we import it really
but um
yeah i don't know
i mean i'm i like
i did
that like british political context is
different from american right
and
i
write for the new statesman magazine for
instance which is like traditionally
left-wing
outlet
um i have come from the left even if i
wouldn't necessarily consider myself
still a part of the left and so on so
like
i hope the book doesn't just get treated
as like yet another socially
conservative take on sex revolution
because even if i'm reaching some
conservative conclusions i'm doing it
via different priors
if that makes sense
yeah why didn't you say i start from
feminist priors and end up with socially
conservative conclusions
yeah some socially conservative
conclusions yeah um
which means that there's sort of
something in it for everyone to hate
except ben shapiro
he's not read the whole thing i'm not
sure how he might think about some of
the early chapters
you've been co-opted by the right wing
of america now and this is your future
so the i i was at um the heterodox
academy jonathan heights organization i
was at that the conference for that this
weekend one of the speakers said
something that kind of i think
sort of
is a good synopsis of of the thesis of
your book that says there are many ways
to change the world few will make it
better many will make it worse
yeah
it's true
there's a rod exclusion quote like that
i can't remember exactly how it's
phrased but um
something like it's really easy to break
things and it's really hard to make
things
which i think is um it's like a really
fundamentally conservative observation
and true
what's wrong with the sexual revolution
then
so
my argument in the book is basically
that there are some really important
ways in which men and women are
different from one another so some of
those differences are physical
and should be fairly obvious
like only women can get pregnant
men are bigger and stronger than women
are on average like on average but also
that difference is massive between the
between the means
and also there are psychological
differences
which a lot of feminism over the last
half century or more has been really
invested in
minimizing
but are i think
definitely there
if you look at the research
um and it will so you just look at the
world around you one of those
differences for instance is that
male sexuality is different from female
sexuality on average that men are more
likely to be into things like casual sex
watching porn buying sex
um all things that have become much more
socially acceptable post-sexual
revolution
and my argument basically is that
the sexual revolution was kicked off by
the pill
and the which
which did a pretty good job of severing
the link between
sex and reproduction and kind of gave
the impression that sex could just be a
leisure activity that it didn't have to
mean anything it could just be sort of
a bit of fun
and my argument is actually that that
idea that sex is just just a bit of fun
doesn't really mean anything suits male
interests much more than it does female
because casual sex in particular
is just
one
one men wanting more than women do
and two women carry all of the risks
associated with it like physical risks
like pregnancy and violence and so on um
some argument basically is it's a bad
deal
originally
it was the sort of thing that was pushed
by
liberals and feminists right this is
exactly the sort of thing yeah yeah yeah
i mean the yes
the popular narrative that i'm
challenging is one that the sexual
revolution was like a feminist
accomplishment
and i don't think that's true i mean
which is not to say that there are some
things about it that have been good for
women i mean
i mean if you look at the story of
recent decades in particular there are
all sorts of ways in which women are
doing great actually like women
women are going to university more often
than men are they are right up until
they have children are doing better in
the workplace you know this is it's not
to say that like everything is
like the battle of the sexes women are
like losing across the board not at all
um
but i think in terms of sexual culture
that i'm concerned i'm concerned for
women i'm also concerned for men i mean
there's a lot in the book about for
instance the really malign influence of
porn on young men
like
like in a superficial and short-term way
it's great to be a really attractive man
in this sexual culture right you can
basically
attract as many partners as you like
you know consequence free sex is freely
available to you
but i think actually in the long run
that's not a very
that's not a happy way to live your life
you say that your complaint is focused
more against liberals than conservatives
why is that
i mean because i'm expecting liberals to
read it
i won't be wrong about that but i that
that's the space that i'm coming from
originally
i went to i went to such a leveling
university
where did you go
i went to sowers in london
i don't even know what that is
it's like a really really small really
crazy university
so i you know i've i've read all of the
all of this radical stuff as a student
and
i'm coming from a feminist background
and coming from
um as i said
the new statesman that i work for is is
historically left-wing so i'm kind of
i'm trying to speak to those people
um
but i mean the books for conservatives
as well because there are bits in it
that i think every everyone will find
um
will find challenging because another
fact that a lot of what you're talking
about here is
conserving some fairly traditional views
around men's and women's roles with each
other about sort of chivalrous conduct
and having constraints on the way that
men and their regression and their
desire for multiple sexual partners like
that that is a fundamentally
conservative value so it seems to me
like
the conservatives would have far less to
disagree with you not again there's
something for everybody to disagree with
but that the conservatives would
probably have far less than
the new wave of liberals
probably yeah although i should say that
the this idea of like constraining male
sexuality which is which is is is
central to my thesis basically
um it is conservative in the sense that
it was
it was considered to be like a
mainstream idea before sexual revolution
in the west but if you look across time
and place like that's not necessarily
considered like a trad thing
to do i mean like if you look for
instance antiquity
the idea that some
high status man would have access to
sexual access to his underlings was like
completely
accepted it's really i don't know if
you've read tom holland's book dominion
no you don't mean tom holland the guy
that plays spider-man do you no i don't
a comment a common mistake no um no he's
a british academic and historian writer
um and he's got this fantastic book
called dominion which is about um
basically about history christianity and
the ways in which christianity
influences the modern world even if we
consider ourselves to be
a religious or post-christian
um
and he has a bit in there where he talks
about me too
um and he really triggered a lot of my
thinking about this actually a few years
ago
where he points out that in say the
roman world
no one would think that harvey weinstein
was doing anything wrong
like the idea that this guy who's at the
top of the top of the tree of his
particular hierarchy would be able to
have sexual access to
any one kind of subordinate to him was
like yeah obviously and actually the
idea that he should be
that he should be constrained
is holland argues a very christian idea
um and you know i'm i'm not christian
i'm not coming at this from a religious
perspective
um but it's worth pointing that out you
know like this is not necessarily a
normal thing to think
the window of trad sort of shifts over
time right like no one's actually going
that far back so okay so the sexual
revolution happens like surely women
have benefited with
uh no more shame and stigma around
enjoying sex and stuff like that like
who who benefited from the sexual
revolution overall
yeah so the shame and stigma thing i
mean
yes that is definitely one outcome i
mean like i think that one of the
one of the things that i'm trying to
push in this book and that is i shared
with um
like mary harrington and nina power that
you've had on the show before they we
yeah we're on this we're on the same
page about this like
challenging the idea of progress um
particularly from a feminist perspective
this idea that
um
history has a shape
and everything is always getting better
and better
and the the sexual revolut you know
everything post-sexual revolution is
necessarily better than what came before
i just don't think it's true i think
that's nonsense
like we're looking at a massive
historical event triggered primarily by
technology
of course there are going to be upsides
and downsides yeah
um
the
yeah so i think it is absolutely the
case that
that women now
can be much more open about sexuality
and i'm more able to enjoy
sex in certain circumstances and stuff
that's true
but i also think that to some extent
like
we're social animals and we're very
responsive to
norms
and what i think has happened is kind of
uh
the norms have just
spun on a sixpence and now whereas
previously it would have been the case
that young women for instance were like
protecting their virginity and their
reputation had been chased and so on was
considered very important socially now
if anything it's the
opposite or not quite the opposite but
that
now the pressure actually is on for
women to be
up for it
and to be just as like sexually
adventurous as the guys and you know
like there's
it's like a slightly painful
um
there's a contradiction within that
which is really hard to navigate for
young women we're on the one hand
like
it's good to be
sexually open it's good to sort of um
base your reputation on being
really sexy
but also there is actually a penalty if
your body count is too high
which is quite which is quite difficult
and i think a lot of young women don't
necessarily realize that as well like
they're actually treading a really
difficult tight rope
um
which is why i think this idea of like
oh well people can do whatever they want
now like you know we're all we're all
free to behave as we want sexually i
just don't think it's true
because every like every culture has
expectations in relation to sex has
norms in relation to sex i think that
what we've done though is that we had
some quite
deeply embedded norms which were thrown
out the window as a consequence of
sexual revolution and now there's like a
sort of halting effort to maybe rebuild
them
sometimes they're
very implicit
and
it's kind of the wild west out there
basically
and
who's enforcing this then where's this
coming from are you suggesting that men
are weaponizing women to believe that
they should have a particular type of
uh sexual proclivity that then plays
into men's hands because they get more
variety
i don't think there's a conspiracy i
don't think that anyone is enforcing it
i think that it's just everyone like
responding to incentives as individuals
um and that knits together to create
the the culture that we see before us
so
like yeah it is it is in the interests
of
of men who want to sleep around to
encourage
women to
to match them you know in that kind of
behavior so that's clearly going on at
an individual level but then in terms of
like
women's magazines encouraging their
readers
to do the same i have some i i did a lot
of digging through women's magazines for
this book
and um
like there are some really grim articles
out there what were your least favorite
headlines
i can't remember exactly the wording of
it but there's a whole genre of um
articles in women's ma in womb's media
about encouraging women not to catch
feelings or i mean the way that it's
phrased is
um how anyone of any gender cannot catch
feelings when they're having casual sex
and how to have casual sex in like a fun
feminist way etc etc but like we know
that women are much more likely to bond
quickly with their sexual partners we
know that they just much less likely to
like casual sex
um
something that's
a really interesting and really marked
difference between men and women
on average on in um sexuality is women's
sexual disgust threshold is a lot lot
lower so women will get the ick much
easier
than men will
but if you're going to participate if
you're going to have sex like a man you
have to overcome all of those instincts
right and so there's a whole genre of
women's bags that will basically
like instruct
their young readers
in how to suppress
their instincts
and have sex that actually they kind of
know deep down they shouldn't be having
which i think is really bleak
and
yeah and and i think that just
representing that is feminist in any way
interestingly looking at it from a man's
perspective i i agree that this is
bad for women i don't think that it
serves their interests i think that the
biological predisposition that women
have when it comes to sexual partners
trying to decouple having sex first off
having sex and and making babies was
decoupled but then having sex and
um having emotions getting attached was
decoupled and that second one the the
pill for that is i mean you know what is
it is it it's ten vodkas deep like does
that really help you know you wake up in
the morning and you feel but
you use this uh analogy about the fact
that
marilyn monroe was a sort of very
attractive woman that was
weaponized commercialized utilized by a
society that wanted to sexualize women
and this was at the benefit of hughes
hugh hefner's the sort of
high status man who was able to sleep
with lots of women and and continue to
do this
i agree i think that you're right it is
bad for women but
very few men are huge and what you're
seeing in the modern society is this
most women are probably dissatisfied
with the way that their sexual um
uh
pursuits are going
most men now the number of men reporting
no sex between the ages of 18 and 30 has
tripled to nearly 30 percent in the last
10 years so the matthew principle kicks
off here so i think on average it's bad
for pretty much everybody i think that
the sort of amount of sexual
satisfaction
has lowered for everybody and you have
this huge underclass of sexless men
which is where in cell blackpill mgtow
red some parts of the red pill the
manosphere men's rights
all of these movements are
as far as i can see they're big cops
from men who are now in a sort of sexual
wasteland
where they're really really struggling
to find connection so i think that it's
i understand that from a feminist
perspective it is bad for women and that
there are higher costs that they pay
but being a listless
liminal space man with no desire from
any female that you give your attention
to is not a good situation to be in
either
yeah i completely agree
yeah i'd add to that things like rates
of erectile dysfunction among young men
are like insanely high
um which is probably true with porn
maybe also to do with easterns in the
environment i don't know
i was eating some edamame beans the
other day and everyone at the table
who's like big into health and fitness
look disgusting apparently edamame beans
have got tons of estrogen in who knew
story can't you
that's probably
don't get into the argument but yeah a
few men a few many views right so
they're the ones that are losing yeah
yeah no this is this is completely true
and i think as well that there's this
like um
antagonism between feminists and
like in let's say in cells broadly um
which does
i think very much come down to these
innate differences between male and
female sexuality and the fact that we
don't really talk about them enough
which means i think that you end up with
um the sexes really misunderstanding
each other right so like feminists will
look at incels
and
like completely not understand
why it would be so frustrating to be a
young man who can't get laid like i
think a lot of
women are like surprisingly clueless
about male sexuality in all sorts of
ways like definitely the dark side of
male sexuality but also just like its
intensity i think most most women cannot
can't just can't like directly empathize
at all and similarly in cells i think
would look at women and be like but you
can walk out into the street and pick up
half a dozen guys you know within five
minutes you must be living heaven on
earth and women like but i don't want
that and so you end up with this
everyone thinks that like the other the
other side has it easy
um which has a lot to do with the fact
of just this like these quite
fundamental biological differences
making it hard for us to empathize with
one another and this is added to
a culture in which
like not only are those sexuality
differences routinely denied but like
the the existence of sexual dimorphism
is routinely denied
it's like how can you possibly like
successfully navigate the sexual
landscape if you don't even think men
and women exist as discrete categories
do you think that inventing the pill was
an error then
no because i think
i mean socially no like that there are
um
mary harrington will probably talk to
you about the environmental consequences
of the pearl um and yeah we've just
mentioned estrogen that's like that's
another story socially i think no i mean
i think it is
i'm personally grateful for the fact
that my life is not entirely dominated
by child bearing which it would have
been in a previous era i'm not going to
expect to have 10 children and to spend
my whole life either pregnant or
postpartum
i think it's more that
we haven't really negotiated with the
social consequences
and that's what i'm trying that's the
sort of conversation that i'm trying to
initiate because we you know we have we
have the power to i'm not like a
complete i
i have a sort of materialist analysis of
all of this and i think
in the end it does come down to
um things like the pill things like
changes in the economy you know i think
so often you get the popular
narrative of feminist history is
basically sees it as being driven by
particularly inspiring feminists
who just kind of
give really strong arguments and
everyone's persuaded and this is what
you know this is what gives us the vote
this is what gives us access to
professions whatever i don't think
that's true i mean clearly there have
been some very impressive feminists
historically but i think that the the
real story of the last century is things
like the washing machine yeah you said
the washing machine helped liberate
women more than any feminist did yeah i
think jordan peterson said the same
thing he's completely right
um he also mentions tampons yeah yeah
there's all sorts of all sorts of
technologies which make um make it
possible for women to have lives outside
of their home or more outside of their
home than previously
um and also changes to the economy which
means that you know if you're in a in a
knowledge economy or a service economy
where male physical strength doesn't
have anything like the economic
importance that it once did
women and men can participate basically
as equals uh you know they're they're
like obviously childbearing makes a
difference but if you're if you're on
the pill you're delaying child bearing
um you're working at a laptop
and
you're operating in a very kind of
gender-neutral social sphere um you
might not even
you might not even like work out you
might have no recognition of the fact
that men and women are physical
profoundly physically different in terms
of things like strength
like from that perspective it looks as
if the whole world is done to neutral
um
and so that's kind of
that's that is the sort of social
context in which this idea of the the
differences between men and women being
socially constructed or being trivial
makes sense
but actually that's like a very very
superficial
analysis of what's going on i actually i
mean one the physical differences are
still profound but also those
psychological differences go really deep
because we're talking about
hundreds of thousands of years of
evolutionary history
feeding into us having these really
distinct reproductive roles and that
and that leading to us having
quite different modes of sexuality
didn't you say that the
uh
usa women's football team was beaten by
the dallas under-15s football team
yeah yeah there's
there are like several examples of this
yeah of elite women's teams
being beaten by teenage boys i think
that the
the fastest woman on the in 100 meters
on the planet gets beaten by
about 100 or 200 under 17s
in america 217 men in america i mean
the whole
like the discussion around uh
male and female
physical strength differences are purely
due to the fact that girls get told that
they need to play with
dolls and guys go and lift
lift little trucks and stuff
it feels like larping to me it feels
like everybody is living this sort of
charade and nobody can bear themselves
to to pull out of it like it's that
that's wild but when it comes to the
psychological differences there's a
little bit more um i guess
plausible room for maneuver there
because you can't see the manifest as
much and when you've also got a
discussion about people being able to
transition from
different genders
the male brain and the female brain and
traits that you put them on and take
them off like clothes
yeah and there are outliers you know
there are there are like less so
physically i mean you do sometimes get
really strong women or whatever but even
then i mean i do
um
my husband and i are both powerlifters
and just i don't think that you can
spend five minutes
in a
power lifting gym and not be
aware of the fact that men and women
strength differences are massive even if
there are obviously some really strong
women do you pull conventional or sumo
conventional
what about the husband also conventional
good it's a family of non-cheaters i'm
adamant that sumo's cheating
um
yeah i mean and then i see i've been you
know trading at this for years and then
i see
like novice men
warming up with my one rep maximum then
[Laughter]
it's just
it's just like
the pure reality of it but i mean if
people people don't participate in those
kind of sports also things like martial
arts if you don't participate in that
you wouldn't necessarily know it
um but on the psychological differences
yeah there
there are there are more outliers there
are some people who are really atypical
for their sex and there clearly is like
a lot of space for
culture to intervene
um
but it's so on an individual level if
you know what if you know someone's sex
you don't necessarily know anything
really about their personality
it's more than at the population level
when you're talking about millions of
people
that's when you see it
play out and like
something that is really interesting and
really makes clear that how profound
these differences are is you look at
things like university campuses
and look at their sex ratio
on
campuses where there are more women than
men so men are the rarer sex
there's more hookup culture because the
rarer sex is able to set the terms more
easily and then on campuses where there
are more men and women you have the
inverses more monogamy
and that's the sort of thing where yes
there will be individual outliers but
you can't deny the differences when you
when you see it playing out in those
kind of larger
arenas
well that sex ratio hypothesis is
kind of the basis as well for a ton of
hypergamy that as you have
uh an ever-increasing group of
high-performing women and ever
decreasing group of underperforming men
that are dropping out of college that
aren't getting as educated women aged 21
to 29 earn 1 111 pounds more on average
than the equivalent man so during the
period when women are seeking a mate
they're unable to find what
fundamentally on average women want to
find a mate that is more statusful
wealthier and better educated than they
are those are the cues typically that
they were attracted to but now women are
able to gain status earn more and become
better educated than men at higher rates
than men which is what's causing this
sort of upward tilt toward
turbo chad at the top sleeping with
everybody
this listless sexless men
underclass down here and then the
wistful women and alpha widows that are
in this sort of world i mean this is
this is the most interesting dynamic
that i think there is at the moment when
it comes to dating it's got downstream
implications economically it's got
downstream implications when you think
about um population growth population
decline culture
crime you know you don't want this huge
underclass of sexless men roaming the
streets when you get into a relationship
as a man your testosterone goes down
when you have a child your testosterone
goes down again because it's
advantageous it's adaptive for you to
not be going out doing reckless [ __ ]
when you've got a baby and a wife at
home to look after so all of this i mean
this is ju
it is by far the most interesting
dynamic i think that's happening in the
world at the moment
yeah and this is the subject of so my
last chapter is called marriage is good
um and a lot of people who've just seen
the contents page sort of assume that
it's a
you know christian argument or whatever
but actually it's it's making exactly
it's like it's like a very rational
secular argument for actually if you
look at what happens to a society when
you get rid of monogamous marriage and
you compare
our society and others and past and also
look at societies where polygamy is the
norm like most
society i think it's about 80 of
societies on the anthropological record
have had polygamy
as a
social acceptable thing so you end up
with
the
you know the chads
who are having multiple wives and then
you've got men who never marry at all
and you do also have some monogamy in
the middle like it's normally not quite
that extreme but
that it seems is basically our natural
state as a species
and because it's just it just recurs
again and again and again
and that that minority of cultures that
have been monogamous including
western cultures
are unusual
but up and it's not like it does sort of
have to be imposed like you know like a
lot of
elite men will cheat for instance and
you know they take on extra wives if
they could like people
monogamy is not really our natural state
it does have to be socially enforced but
it also is like amazingly successful
anthropologists talk about the puzzle of
monogamous marriage in that it is weird
to see that
a culture like ours would have developed
it in the first place because it clearly
doesn't suit the interests of elite men
you'd think that the elite men would
want would want to have multiple wives
which of course they do
but the reason they think that it's
become as successful as it has is
because monogamous societies do well
more stable
they're more they're more stable they're
also more productive
so they they colonize other parts of the
world basically because they're
wealthy and you know striving and
successful and then they impose their
marriage norms elsewhere
think about it this way i've only just
thought about this
the naturalistic fallacy gets used a lot
with this right look ancestrally we
maybe don't have tons of evidence that
we're a monogamous species therefore
monogamy is not the strategy that was
supposed to go down yeah if you accept
the fact that non-monogamous societies
are more unstable and are going to exist
for less of an amount of time that means
that the living standards are going to
be lower that means that mortality al
all of the things that you care about
right are going to be out of the window
yeah
what if monogamy for the individual
sometimes can be sub-optimal but on
average is optimal for the culture as a
whole in the same way as when seat belts
got introduced people didn't want to
wear them and a lot of the time it's not
just you that you're saving it's also
other people in the car because if you
don't have your seatbelt on you bounce
around and you smash up everybody else
as well
maybe
a different way to frame monogamy is
that
it's it's kind of like following the law
a little bit it's it's a a small
individual sacrifice that you make that
does perhaps make for some people
sub-optimal living standards but only a
little bit
but the reason that you do that is to
contribute to
the entire stability of society
yeah i've heard i can't remember who
who came up with this but i've heard
monogamy referred to as sexual socialism
basically it's a redistribution strategy
for sure yeah yeah i mean
i mean
mentioned jordan reece again he got in
trouble for saying something along these
lines i can't remember exactly
i brought it i brought it up with him at
the start of the year
yeah because it sounds really
authoritarian but i think what he was
describing though is basically we're
describing where it's like socially
prescribed it's not even necessarily
legally required it's just considered to
be the norm you know cheating is
considered to be bad
you can't have a second wife
um and yeah there are also i mean there
are other they're good outcomes also in
terms of things like child abuse and
domestic violence um which obviously is
something feminists are very interested
in
like polygynous societies have much
higher rates of both because the
households with multiple wives and their
children are like
full of conflict
hundreds of times more likely that a
child is going to be killed if they're
in the household with one parent that
isn't a biological parent yeah 100 times
more likely yeah yeah it's yeah it's
insane
it's wild okay so what's what's sexual
disenchantment
so
um
[Music]
social disenchantment is basically
i took it from max baber the sociologist
who
wrote about um
uh disenchantment of the natural world
as part of the enlightenment so when you
um
people used to believe pre-enlightenment
the natural world was kind of possessed
by spirits and had like
agency
and specialness like infused within it
and then
we become more rational whatever post
enlightenment and realize that actually
it's all just like scientific forces at
play
i think that it's not it's not my term i
i i borrowed it from aaron sabario he's
american writer um
sexual disenchantment is what happens
post-sexual revolution where you used to
think of sex as having this kind of
special nurse i mean within christianity
being like a sacrament within marriage
and then
now it's stripped of all of that meaning
and it just becomes basically
any old say any old social interaction
like it's just a means of having fun
basically it doesn't necessarily mean
anything i mean
the point that i make in the book is
actually basically no one really
believes in sexual disenchantment people
talk about it a lot
and particularly like progressives and
liberal feminists will talk about it as
if
as if it's an ideal like we should of
course get rid of all these like stupid
old-fashioned ideas about sex having
some like
innate specialness
um but actually people don't really
behave as if that's true
because people behave almost always as
if actually sex does have
a special status and it's a special
status you can't necessarily define very
easily but people feel it like people
care if they're if they get cheated on
even in even in the polyamorous
community like if you go into any
polyamorous
subreddit or whatever you will find
people
really struggling with jealousy as this
like intense instinctive thing that
they're trying to override and they
can't quite do it um people i mean
sexual harassment in the workplace like
the
i get really frustrated with feminists
who claim simultaneously that
um sex workers work
and that we should like get rid of all
these hang-ups about
um selling sex being any different from
working in mcdonald's or you know
selling any other kind of service but
then they also get so sensitive about
any like perceived section impropriety
in their workplace
what like
like being touched by a boss for
instance like not even in a
like a really aggressive assaulting way
but just you know women getting touched
on the arm or something like that or
being asked out
in a context that you don't really feel
comfortable you know all that kind of me
too stuff which is quite low level
like if that if it's really the case
that sex work is work then what is the
problem with being asked by your boss to
give him a [ __ ]
right it's it's it's it's work it's just
a service it's like being asked to do
over time or maybe make a coffee or make
a coffee yeah and no one actually thinks
that that it's just like making a coffee
so i think that the sexual
disenchantment idea is really just
theoretical
it's a rhetorical kind of
move
um
but actually doesn't really describe
reality and doesn't really describe how
people feel i mean it's kind of just an
inconvenient fact that if you're
if you're trying to be super rational
and you're trying to resist
anything like remotely traditional or
religious or you know anything
um
[Music]
anything old-fashioned
then the fact that people feel very
differently about sex and they do about
other things is kind of inconvenient it
felt like an aberration right it's like
oh this is just and it the analogy drawn
with the um non-monogamy community is so
correct one of my friends out here in
austin was telling me about the first
time that his wife brought somebody else
back
and he was on the floor of the bathroom
dry wretching
but at the time he's not married at the
time was adamant that this was just him
working through his ego and this is in
part of the process this is part of the
processing thing i'm like dude
that's you're not choosing to throw up
that's something way way way behind
conscious programming that's innate
that's built in um but is it you that is
this your quote that says few liberal
feminists are willing to draw the link
between the culture of sexual hedonism
they promote and the anxieties of a
campus rate that have emerged at the
exact same time yeah
yeah that's yeah
yeah because
i think what's going i think what's
going on a lot with me too
is that
what
what me what was described during me too
and still is i guess i mean it's still
is still going on in different forms
right
was not always rape
right
like some so with like going back to
weinstein for instance some of what he
did was like straightforwardly illegal
um and he was convicted of it therefore
but a lot of what was described is much
more
somewhere in the middle you know much
more open to interpretation
um and often what women were talking
about was just like feeling creeped out
or feeling like
like exactly this dry retching on the
bathroom floor feeling like your
instincts are telling you something
even if you can't quite rationalize it
and often this was
like
expressed in terms of consent because in
the liberal feminist framework the only
thing you're really allowed to talk
about is consent because you because
all the old-fashioned norms are out the
window you're not allowed to talk about
chivalry you're not allowed to talk
about
um like
any kind of instinctive
feeling of disgust or discomfort that
you have
kind of has to be suppressed but you are
allowed to talk about consent and so
everything had to be expressed in the
form
in like the language of consent so i
talk about for instance the aziz ansari
case you might remember i can't remember
the name of the grace i think was her
her pseudonym
this woman who went on a date with the
actors he's ansari went back to his
house afterwards and he kind of he
didn't rape her and he didn't do
anything illegal but he just kind of
subtly pressured her into doing sex
things that she didn't really want to do
and then later she
wrote a sort of
first-hand account of this
um
and he got in trouble but it was one of
those
it was it was a bit later on in me too
it was one of those ones that provoked a
lot of discussion because it was because
it was a borderline one like he hadn't
had he done anything wrong he definitely
hadn't done anything illegal
um
the idea that he had
that he had violated her consent just
didn't really stack up just based on her
own story
i think what's often going on here is
it's to do with this
pressure that women feel
to have sex like men
and to try and have emotionless sex and
to try and just like
you know to do the sexual disenchantment
thing and just treat it like a like a
leisure activity
but they can't actually quite do it and
they feel like they feel sexual disgust
they feel shame they feel like these
deep painful emotions
and the only person sometimes to blame
is the man
even though he actually might not have
done anything wrong really or he i mean
he probably wasn't behaving like a
gentleman
but he wasn't doing anything illegal and
he wasn't doing anything really wrong
according to like
the the standards of the day
it's just that the stands of the day are
not actually very good for women
that's it you've nailed it you've
absolutely nailed it there and you're
right the the outlet for uh pushback and
and for
distaste the only one that is there is
the man and the only framing through
which you can talk about this is consent
which is where false allegations i think
sometimes come in that perhaps you
repurpose ike
as
guilt as
it does something criminal yeah now it's
rape yeah
and of course the nature of it is that
there are only two people there there
weren't any witnesses and so it's
everyone's like analysis of something
that's gone in the past it's just really
difficult
um and you know to be fair to a lot of
men they're being
they're being raised in the same culture
where you're told that this is that
women love it you know they i mean they
haven't necessarily watched like sex in
the city but it's the same
it's the same milieu where you where
like having sex like a man is
aspirational and the idea is
i i write a lot in the book about pop
culture examples of women who are
clearly aspirational fictional
characters
who
have loads of casual sex love it like
don't have any emotional connection to
the men
that they use for sex and this is this
is like this is this is aspirational you
know and so and young men are seeing
this as well and they're also watching
porn which gives a completely unrest
realistic perspective on what women
like
and so you know they're clueless
basically they're playing by the rules
of the game as well or at least by the
the cultural influences of the game that
they think are going on another another
problem that you have here
in the
asymmetric warfare of the sexes is that
men who begin to get a little bit of
resentment for women let's say that
they've had their heart broken in the
past but that they are um within the
standard where they can keep having sex
right they're not one of the underclass
they're actually someone that can keep
on doing it
if they become aware of the fact that
girls are trying to play this game of
detached emotionless sex if they fully
become conscious of that they go oh okay
let's see who can win at this game the
most because it's not going to be you
it's going to be me and they can you
know this isn't to say again on average
this isn't to say that some men don't
get attached after the first time they
have sex where they go some of my
friends fall pretty hard uh but
they if they can weaponize that they can
do a ton of damage as well and
yeah
i don't know
this may be an argument that everybody
just needs to not be able to have sex
until the age of 25 and then when they
do they're like look i'm fully
emotionally
balanced i've been through a bunch of
breakups i didn't have sex during the
during the
relationship i kind of know what i like
and what i don't like blah blah blah i
don't know i it's just
so many of these
marriage chris
that used to be what it was you weren't
allowed to have sex before you got
married
which gave which gave like men in
particular a massive incentive to get
their [ __ ] together because
because if you can't
if you can't get married until you say
like achieve certain adult things like
you've got a job you've got um a house
you know or like you've got
whatever the system is like a certain
amount of money that you can demonstrate
your sort of
eligibility as a husband if you have to
get all of your ducks in a row before
you can have sex i mean you can
potentially buy sex
but you can't have it like socially
illicit then that that's a huge
incentive
to behave yourself and to do pro-social
stuff whereas if you have a scenario now
where either
either you're
like attractive enough that you can get
sex casual sex without having to
to do anything really except be like
moderately charming
or you can get sex
through all you all you have access to
porn which like gives you the
gives some of the same like feedback
from your environment as if you were
actually having sex like
i mean this would get so this will get
so much worse with sex robots
where all of a sudden you can like
basically bypass all of the effort that
you might historically have had to put
in in order to access sex you can just
buy a sex robot and you can spend your
whole life
playing video games never going to the
gym never showering never having a job
and you still get access to this thing
that your ancestors like
fought tooth and nail to get access to
even without the sex robots men are
retreating i think from from the dating
market
terrifying
terrifying rates there's a
a quote that rob henderson came up with
which is this a similar sort of dynamic
that we're talking about here
says norms were loosened around being an
absentee father so more men took the
option but nobody wants to admit it
because it upsets people instead we
retreat to discussions of poverty and
economics because talking about family
and parenting makes people feel weird
and judgmental but young men will only
do what's expected of them and a lot did
used to be expected there were social
norms to work hard provide take care of
loved ones and so on today these norms
have largely dissolved young men have
responded accordingly
yeah yeah he's very very smart for
benson he's completely right
um
yeah i mean i think that i think that
the
the line i have in the book about debbie
dads is that when
when motherhood became a biological
choice for women fatherhood became a
social choice for men
what do you mean by that
in the when
contraception and legalized abortion
became available
i mean the sh that basically killed the
shotgun marriage
pretty much immediately because it no
longer served the same social purpose
that it had before
um
but the nature of contraception is such
that nothing is 100 foolproof and
actually the pill particularly in its
earliest incarnations wasn't that great
and still isn't that great because it
depends a lot on the user using it
properly so if you're using it properly
it's like 99 plus effective but in
reality it's more like 91
so you end up with a lot of unplanned
pregnancies and there will always be
some women who don't want to have a
termination for whatever reason
um
but if you're in a social context where
like
there isn't necessarily considered to be
a link between sex and reproduction and
getting pregnant is considered to be
like
this
unwelcome aberration rather than
literally the whole point
then
it becomes much more socially acceptable
for men to not stick around because they
say well you chose this
you know
you're on your own which is yeah i mean
obviously there have always been cases
of
people i've had some critics point this
out you know they've always been cases
of men abandoning
their wives or abandoning women that
they think that they've made pregnant
outside of marriage you know they've
always been scoundrels they've always
been unwanted pregnancies whatever like
that's absolutely true
but
rates of out of wedlock burst now are
completely historically unprecedented
which is kind of weird because you would
think that
giving women the technology that enables
them to control their fertility would
reduce single motherhood but it's done
the opposite
because humans are humans are
complicated creatures that's what i
learned from mary harrington that you
introduce the pill
single motherhood goes up like who the
[ __ ] could have predicted that right
that's four degrees of detachment away
you know
it's
so interesting but also kind of tragic
but
it's it seems like women
it was it was a perfect storm right you
had the the decoupling socially then you
had the decoupling biologically but you
haven't had the decoupling
emotionally
it's still that
fundamentally that there will be some
women that are able to have sex like a
man and there will be some able some man
the men that are able to have sex like a
man but on average it used to be
something that you work toward for a
long time it used to be the sort of
thing and think about now i was uh sent
another article by rob the other day
where he was talking about why is it
that parents
tend
to
select
when when their daughter or son brings
home a new potential partner they look
at things like job title earnings family
and he asked why is that the case why is
it that you look at these when you know
they're not looking at how hot they are
not looking at a detraction and stuff
like that even kindness kind of takes a
little bit of a back seat and it's
less falsifiable basically the fact is
look these are the things that are going
to be the most likely to become
um
grandchild optimizing
algorithms
do you have status do you have money do
you have
the right family behind you if you've
got those i'm probably going to have
grandchildren uh all of the other ones
are wishy-washy and and kind of uh easy
to
to fake in a way
um
why
why is it then that loveless sex isn't
empowering
yeah i mean because because
your animal brain
which none of us are completely in
control of
for women in particular even if there
are some outliers as you mentioned i
mean often the outliers are often women
who
who don't get attached to sex for
instance have like a history of sexual
trauma there's often not a very healthy
reason behind it but like accepting the
fact that there are outliers
your animal brain thinks that this guy
is going to knock you up and like you
are going to become
a profoundly vulnerable mother baby dyad
you know like human infants are insanely
vulnerable they need so much more care
than any other as as far as i know any
other species young
um
and mothers are also extremely
vulnerable in the later stages of
pregnancy and and during infancy you
have to put so much energy and sacrifice
so much in order to raise this child to
adulthood
and that before
like five minutes ago in our
evolutionary history was what happened
what was certainly what you risked
happening if you had
sex
social sex
and so
like our brains are still primed for
that
and that's the whole
that's the whole purpose behind
emotional
attachment to your sexual partner and
also the whole purpose behind like
choosing your sexual partner and the
fact that women do tend to be a lot
cheesier than men
there's these quite funny studies that
have been done several times where they
um
they get like quite attractive strangers
to go up to men and women i think on
university campuses normally and
proposition them and
when when the women proposition male
strangers they almost always say yes or
if any of they say no it's because they
have a girlfriend or whatever whereas
when the men proposition of women they
always say no
because women like their filter is
impregnable
um
and there's a reason for that if you
don't want some some like to be knocked
up by some bows this is one of the
reasons why prostitution is as traumatic
as it is i mean there are all there are
all of the
physical risks involved in prostitution
like rates of murder are insanely high
you know it's
it's it's
if we were to compare it to another
profession it would be by far the most
dangerous profession ever and i rates of
phd are much higher than in the military
for instance
but one of the reasons why it's so
profoundly distressing is that women
have this really really strong instinct
to like vet their sexual partners and to
only have sex with men who seem like
good prospects and women also have a
very heart a very low sexual disgust
threshold
which means that they get the ick very
readily with a man that they don't fancy
and what what women in prostitution are
basically required to do is to override
that
and to suppress those instincts if you
talk to women who've
who've experienced it they often talk
about like working really hard to
dissociate from their physical feelings
it is that is that retching on the
bathroom floor thing i mean actually
rachel moran who's
a prostitution survivor and has written
this amazing book called paid for which
is a memoir of her experiences
um she talks about that the fact that
not vomiting is one of the most
important skills a prostitute can have
because your
your physical urge to run away and to
cry into vomit is that strong that you
have to like
fight it down
and i think that if
you know of in much less extreme
circumstances obviously but when women
are trying to like
to to
to
to play the masculine role and imitate
male sexuality and to enjoy sex in the
way that they think they're supposed to
they are basically obliged to suppress
their instincts
which isn't isn't at all psychologically
healthy
has normalizing sex work like only fans
been a benefit for women
i mean there clearly are some women only
fans who make a lot of money from it so
there are some
winners i mean
they
they are very unusual
most women on only fans probably make a
loss in terms of the amount of time they
have to spend because the burrito
distribution on only fans is wild and
most of the women who do really well on
it are already celebrities and already
quite wealthy
so this idea that you can just be
like
as long as you're sufficiently pretty
you log on and you're making a fortune
is not true and i'm sure has been
deliberately whipped up that idea by
only fans because they're the only
people actually really profiting at the
end of the day
um i mean i think the only fans is not
like street prostitution or brother
prosperity like it's clearly not the
same
i
like it's pretty gross and and you will
have men asking you to do things that
really turn your stomach
but it's clearly not like physically
dangerous i think that the main
risk of only fans is your
ability to have a long-term relationship
afterwards
because you end up putting your images
out in the world and you can't get them
back that's the nature of the internet
and often only fans creators get their
images stolen
and so they'll be shared and they don't
even get any money from it
and
the risk is
in the future that even though
men don't always admit it
the sexual double standard is still
actually really alive and well if you so
such a double standard being when
men are kind of permitted to be a bit
promiscuous and that's okay socially but
women tend to be punished for
promiscuity i think that only fans goes
beyond promiscuity you know
the double standard didn't occur it's
not men wanking on camera and then
trying to find a wife and them saying uh
my friends shared something in a
whatsapp chat earlier on and that kind
of looks a little bit like you
what about um
normalizing uh
like love sex workers like sex workers
are you should be completely fine with
your partner doing only fans or uh
perhaps even escorting
i mean crazy what kind of
yeah i mean either
i think if i think if a man is really
comfortable with that that's like a red
flag to me
honestly like again it's an example of
men suppressing their instincts because
the the instinct towards jealousy is so
strong
and again has such an obvious
evolutionary
origin to it
because if you're putting loads of
resources into raising children that
you've had with this woman you want to
know they're yours like that's make
guarding is what the
biologists call it and it's it's so
common that i think it's considered to
be a human universal
and yeah like there are there are loads
of
sort of unwelcome phenomena that come
from that you know jealousy is often
um the motive behind domestic violence
for instance
it's like you know
you mentioned the naturalistic fallacy
like the fact that it's natural doesn't
mean it's necessarily good but it does
also mean that trying to completely
override it is probably not gonna work
like you have to find a way of
accommodating your instincts you can't
just try and suppress them and try and
like
like rewrite the human blueprint well
that's where that's where i think the um
it's not men that are encouraging women
to do only funds
i don't see men on the internet
saying that you should go and you girl
should ditch your job and go and do it
the only people online saying sex work
is real work seems to be women yes men
are the ones that are paying for their
images once they're in the game
but i think
that's because once women cross that
threshold and become a sex worker or
whatever they're almost
kind of not subhuman but they're in a
different category right and it's like
oh well they're doing it i didn't get
them into it so i'm just going to
continue to fund them but if you were to
say
to most men i think
would you advise that pretty girl to get
into only fans so that you can see her
nudes
most of them would say
probably not probably not but almost
every healthy man would say no right
they'd say no i'd try and go out with
her or maybe she should just go and
enjoy her life or do whatever but once
they're in the game that's what's going
to happen but you have this this very
bizarre sort of cartel
i don't know it's like
uh
self not self oppression but like
self capitalization from women of women
encouraging other women to go and do the
game despite the fact that the chances
of you making money on only fans is
minuscule when it comes to actually
making the tens of thousands of dollars
a day that the the biggest creators make
and
yeah i mean
even even if you were able to have an
unbelievably secure only fans
that was never able to leak your photos
online you have two choices for the
remainder of your life when you get into
talking to a new partner you can either
tell them the truth
and
regardless of how comfortable that guy
is with his sexuality finding out that
his misses forget body count even if
you've only slept with
one other person but that was something
that you did
you can't
like left brain your way out of thinking
that that is
oh god well if she did that in the past
does this mean that she's maybe going to
she's a risk for promiscuity in the
future like the cook radar is so hyper
attuned for men which is why we get more
jealous or the other one is to lie to
him
cut radar is interesting
phrase
game because i have you because i have
used the i've i've i have to write it in
the book but i've
um like talked about on twitter nonce
radar
i think that women have really strongly
i mean i think men do as well but i
think women in particular have a really
strong like it's i think it's certainly
a sexual disgust thing is that feeling
of like this guy is creepy
and i think that it i think it's like
female intuition right and i think it's
coming it's probably partly coming from
wanting to protect yourself is also
partly wanting to protect your children
you've got that like this guy's bad news
yeah if i'm gonna sleep with him what's
he going to do to the kids perhaps down
the line i saw i got to tell you about
this uh
meme that i saw so carl benjamin sargon
of akkad a guy who uh has incredibly
conservative views about this stuff but
aligns completely with what we're saying
here he posted a meme the other day and
it had a girl from only fans in like a
bikini or lingerie or whatever sort of
dancing away on one side and had michael
scott from the office on the other side
of looking strangely and the text said
we call it female empowerment and they
will dance naked for the price of a
cheeseburger
yeah
yeah i mean this question you raise
about why women encouraging each other
to do it you're right i mean one
exception i would give do you have a
friend who went on a date with a guy who
said you're so hot you should be on only
fans
and she did not go on a date with him
again because it was just so obviously i
know failing strategy i think yeah
because
the way that she interpreted it and i
think correctly was that he was
he was clearly not regarding her as like
wife material right and this is this is
i think an error that women do make
sometimes where they don't have a good
understanding of male sexuality and they
don't
it's really interesting i don't know if
you read david buster's book bad men uh
and he talks about the fact that women
tend to assess like short-term partners
and long-term partners based on the same
uh
qualities they want the same things in
all the men they have sex with
men don't do that they have a much lower
standard for their short-term partners
and they do for long-term partners and
so they will be willing to have sex with
a woman that they absolutely would not
marry they would not even introduce to
their friends
and i think a lot of women don't
necessarily know that and so they will
interpret sexual
advances from men as flattering
when actually they are potentially like
cheap you know this is the genesis of
the alpha widow right like this is what
many girls that are liberated sexually
and using tinder and stuff like that
don't get and i think that this is
another i'm actually not so convinced
about quite how big of an of an effect
this is i'd need to see rob go and do
some research about it but certainly
women are able to sleep with men that
they wouldn't be able to get into a
relationship with but the reverse isn't
true and there is an argument that the
the aftershock of this means that those
women are going to constantly pine after
the 9 out of 10 guy that's worth half a
million and so all that
i'm
not sure about how long that would last
for and the echoes of that and stuff
like that but i certainly think that um
what porn has done to men which is to
teach them that women are to be
objectified is similar in part to what
only funds has done to women which is to
teach some women that men are commercial
vehicles to be exploited and that their
sex is just a
it's a commodity you can trade it like
anything else
yeah and it's not i think as well
some women who already like posting a
lot of
raunchy photos on instagram don't
necessarily feel like any fans is that
bigger step it's just
a bit more explicit and you get paid for
it so you can sort of see
the reasoning and what some women say
and i
i get it is that you know yes maybe that
it means that some men in the future
wouldn't want to be in a relationship
with me because i've got these photos
out in the world but i wouldn't want to
be in a relationship with a man like
that anyway if he's going to judge me
sort of thing and the problem with that
is that if you actually look at research
on men it's like that's basically all
men they might not say it
because it's not really socially
acceptable to admit to
but actually is basically all men like
to the point that if a man isn't
bothered
i'd wonder if he had a cuckold fetish
you know and then and then that
obviously brings complications to your
relationship
what did you learn about porn when you
looked at that
for the book
i
mean the thing with porn that i think a
lot of people don't
fully appreciate is that
online porn is a completely different
beast
from like playboy of the 60s i mean i
start the book by writing about playboy
writing like hugh hefner and clearly
like there were
feminists writing at the time about porn
being really grim for women there's this
famous cover of a
an issue of hustler i can't remember
what year it was published in probably
70s
where a woman is being like
um ground up in a meat grinder and her
legs are just sticking out the top it's
really like
of like deliberately grotesque image and
feminist got so upset about it at the
time i think rightly but like they
had no idea
what would happen with the internet
and i think that the thing that's so
sinister
about online porn
is
that
there's this there's this quote i use in
the book
that
the nature of like technocapitalism
is that we are all either above the
algorithm or below the algorithm we're
either writing these we're either
creating these these these pieces of
tech or we're being influenced by them
because we're using them or we're you
know sexually interacting with people
who are using them and porn is such an
amazing example of this because
it's just profit driven that's the point
of it it's not it's not interested in
the well-being of its consumers i mean
whatever pornhub like porn have have
various like advertising
efforts to try and sanitize what they do
but
the whole the whole point of it is
making money and they're really good at
it
and the way that they do it is by
basically creating a super stimulus
which
adults uses brains
and the
like they're incredibly adept at
basically arousing the human body the
human animal like we can't really resist
our animal instincts as quickly as
possible so you log on to
one of these platforms and you look at
the front page
and like everything is designed to make
you as horny as possible as quickly as
possible
and
the
the way the platforms are designed
is to
like introduce you to the super stimulus
and then introduce it to something even
more stimulating and even more
stimulating even more stimulating and so
you end up and i mean so a lot of people
are able to use porn casually quite a
lot of people don't use it at all like a
surprising including men surprising
proportion do you know how much that is
so i read a survey that about a quarter
of millennial men haven't used in the
last month
which quite a lot
but the the
that there's a minority of users who are
like helpless power users
yeah yeah like again it's it burrito is
a play as well like there is a small
number of men who watch
i can't remember the the figure i put in
the book it's something like two percent
of users use it for like seven hours a
week or more
it's a lot of porn do you know um mary
harrington's law of fap entropy
yes whatever you start out wanking to
will get progressively more disgusting
over time and you'll be down in the
depths of blueberry porn before you know
it well yeah
yeah absolutely yeah i mean
like just anecdotally
there are some
very strange things that compulsive porn
users end up being turned on by and like
to the point where they they can't even
like erectile dysfunction being a huge
problem they can't actually have sex
with a real person what's the name for
that
it's not ground pounding what's it
called it's called something oh death
grip syndrome death ground pounding
where the [ __ ] did i pull that from yeah
more unpleasant
i mean death grip syndrome isn't that
nice either
yeah and i talk i write in the book
about um cultural death group syndrome
which is where we've got an incredibly
pornified public life you've got so much
more like sex scenes on tv
advertising billboards whatever i mean
like sex scenes on tv have wrapped up so
quickly just in my lifetime that used to
be edgy and now it's like
you know every drama has to have
like super super explicit sex scenes
every five minutes whatever
so you've got that on the one hand well
i don't think we've ever had this much
explicit sex in public life but then
also people aren't actually having sex
you have the sex recession with sex
depression
where you've got as you were saying
you've got loads of men who are virgins
up into their 20s and so on it's this
really weird
um
what's the word
is is this really weird contradiction
and it's one that the feminists of the
70's who were so upset about porn didn't
foresee interestingly like they were
concerned that porn would
inspire sexual violence and like it's
complicated because it probably does a
bit like in some circumstances so for
instance
choking porn has become so popular
and is so mainstream in a way that it
wasn't at all 20 years ago it used to be
considered a really niche bdsm thing and
even actually in the bsn community was
considered a bit risky whereas now
like
survey data is crazy
for millennials and younger the
proportion of young women who report
being choked by their partners
um sometimes asking for it and sometimes
sometimes non-consensually but it's like
just become insanely mainstream really
quickly and the only mechanism
that i can see for that is porn that
it's it's inspiring a change in sexual
culture
so
so sometimes yeah it's inspiring
more aggressive
behavior from its users
but equally actually sometimes it's like
basically neutering
users like they become actually
incapable of having sex with a real
person and even becoming capable of
being aroused by just normal porn
because they're so they'd like they go
they go down the rabbit hole
continues to
yeah what do
what do most modern feminists think
about porn now then do they think that
it's liberating women and
allowing them to earn and sex work is
real work
it's complicated because i think that
the
like most liberal feminists and sex
posture feminists would definitely think
that there's nothing like inherently bad
about porn
and would absolutely defend the right of
women to produce it and so on but i
think that there's increasingly a view
that actually it's not
it's not great i did a um debate at the
oxford union earlier this year
and the the the proposition was
something like this house welcomes a new
porn it was mostly about any fans but
they ended up being able in general and
i thought i'd be slaughtered because i
thought that the
you know these students were going to be
so sex positive and so i see everything
i had to say and actually i won
surprisingly i had some quite aggressive
questions from the floor
but actually at the end
um our side one so i think that was
because i think actually this generation
i mean this is 18 year olds right so
they've or a bit older they they're the
generation who had porn
like on their private computers on their
phones
from adolescence onwards i mean i'm 30
so i
didn't actually have
my own smartphone or whatever until
teens and above but these are the kids
who who had it from like adolescence and
would expect to be exposed to porn
really young
and it was really formative in their
sexuality
and
i think that
it's hard not to
not to recognize the like the downsides
of that the thing that i see online
i i don't know a single guy that is pro
porn
guys are either neutral porn or
anti-porn like and the ones that are
anti-porn are vehement about it do they
tend to be anti-porn
from like
the
ethical
women's stuff or because of the effect
on them i
from the effect on women's stuff no
um i think that i i actually think that
the guys that are behaviorally addicted
to porn or who have got friends that do
or are scared that they're going to
become it i actually
think in part that they see
the women that are um a part of the pawn
machine as part of the oppressor i think
that they think that they are creating
the content which is causing me to i
have to fap
three or four times a day and and feel
disgusted with myself or waste time or
have this sort of super normal stimuli
problem of not being able to get it open
um
yeah i mean it's another one of those
things where everybody's losing you know
except for the owners of mine geek
they're fine yeah didn't one of those
one of those went on a podcast a few
years ago i remember hearing about how
huge that mind geek empire is it's like
more than 50 of all porn streaming on
the internet goes through them
remembering that porn is still the
biggest
traffic source on the internet and
they've got
it's wild yeah uh
are they british
one of the guys british as well canadian
the guy who only fans is british yes
yeah he's uh i was trying to get him on
i was trying to bring him on because he
seems like a very interesting guy i was
really fascinated by the attempted move
away from explicit content it was
obvious that they had
i don't think that that came from
altruistic means i think that that came
from probably investor problems and [ __ ]
to do with banks so chelsea ferguson if
you know her
she owns admire me dot vip which is
another version of only fans she was on
only fan she found out that it was a
problem she's a friend i've been friends
with her for a very long time she's got
a huge private snapchat she's been a
stripper for a long time in newcastle
and she was telling me that she had to
go to germany germany was the only place
that she could get a bank that would
process payments when they found out
what she was doing so the back end of
stuff i think that that was the
the story about only fans wasn't that
they were trying to clean up the image
it's that they were probably having
investor problems and and operational
[ __ ] on the back end
yeah yeah interesting because that was
one of the
my memory of the timeline is that big
new york times piece about pornhub and
monkey came out
and visa in particular
possibly some other
companies i can't remember
got cold feet and thinking that they
were
inadvertently funding child rape images
and so i guess that that i mean i mean
only fans has loads of kids on it
realistically and i know that they try
they say that they try to make sure that
it's only adults but they can't
realistically do that there are loads of
stories anecdotally of girls
you know
14 15 year old girls or whatever putting
their images up there it is inevitable
if on any of these platforms you can't
really protect against it
what do you mean when you say that
people are not products
so that's the yeah that's the
when i mentioned at the beginning that i
had that big twitter storm about my uh
about my chapter titles and that was
kind of the most
all these like left-wing sex positive
people absolutely outraged at me saying
that people aren't products
i mean it comes back to the sexual
disenchantment point
that if you
if you really think that
sex is meaningless it's just like making
coffee blah blah blah that people can
just like sell sexual access to
themselves like they'd sell any other
kind of service or any other kind of
product
like it's internally consistent
and it's the sort of
the
the phrase that i use in that chapter is
that it's the logic of the punter i mean
that's what punters think that they can
just they don't really see
prostituted women as being properly
human
i think i mean based on the way that
they write about them that doesn't that
doesn't seem to be how they view them
there's like
appalling um
review platforms online where panties
will review
women they've bought sex from
and there's like no human feeling in
there like there's like true psychopathy
on display so so like that probably is
the only population who actually believe
in sexual disenchantment
um
the women they're buying sex from
certainly don't
and
and like
thinking
away from the more extreme end of it in
terms of prostitution as well just
thinking about things like dating apps
which
are also kind of designed like they're
also sort of continuous with the logic
of the punter in that they are designed
to be like shopping
apps that's how they feel you don't feel
using them that different from using
like asos or ebay or whatever
because you swipe swipe swipe and select
your product
um i mean or not of course if you're
like an insult who doesn't get any
matches but for for high status men and
for women that is how it that's how it's
experienced and it's got a really really
consumerist kind of
energy the cat the whole like casual sex
phenomenon um which ought to be the sort
of thing that the left are really
opposed to
you know
my my colleagues at the new statesman
like this all this thought to be
you know we're talking about
this multi-billion pound global empire
of the porn industry we're talking about
a really consumerist attitude towards
other people's
bodies and minds like this this this
isn't conservative or it shouldn't be
like this should be
101 anti-capitalist critique coming from
the left but it isn't and i think that
that's because
a lot of people on the left have
prioritized
like
owning the cons
and
are more interested in tearing down
bourgeois sexual norms and basically
promoting free love at all costs than
they are in thinking about where this
has actually led to a led us to and i
think that this
the last 60 70 years post-sexual
revolution period has been
has been a big experiment in what
happens if you disconnect sex from
reproduction
and you basically discard all of the
like quite finely tuned
norms that used to exist
basically to keep young horny people
away from each other i mean the way that
this is
inter this history is interpreted by
feminists often is is
this all those social norms exist to
control female sexuality
and they did but they also existed to
control male sexuality and the purpose
of it wasn't to oppress women it wasn't
motivated by misogyny it was motivated
by the fact that if sex leads to
reproduction then that's everyone's
concern like that matters to the
community because if you've got
people
young couples producing illegitimate
children like that's
that matters to the family that matters
to the community it it is essential in a
world without contraception to
control young people's
sexuality and that's what those norms
existed for and we threw them out the
window very rapidly
and we've basically seen this play out
over the last
however many decades and i think that
the the results are in and they're not
very promising
that's really really good i i learned
from mary when she came on the show
about the fact that a lot of the rules
and the norms that are set are by the
elite
and they're usually not the ones that
suffer the impact it's a luxury belief
right it's a hold that um men don't need
to hold the door open for you and that
having chivalry and constraints on male
behavior
that's not needed by some
upper-middle-class woman whose husband
has got a postgraduate degree
because there are
maybe levels of education or or norm
enforcement that have occurred just
through his upbringing and her
upbringing that means that it doesn't
matter what you don't think about is
that the underclass or the working-class
guy and girl who perhaps haven't had
those same sort of levels of norms
enforced and maybe they don't know that
not hitting your wife is that big of a
deal and then when the culture starts to
erode and evaporate that away you go
well
the people that made the rules or that
encourage the norms to be dissolved and
not the ones that are suffering they're
dissolving
yeah rob henson actually i think he uses
polyamory as his one of his examples is
his original luxury beliefs essay
where if you're
a high status
person let's say in like the bay area
where everyone loves polyamory like
polyamory is really is just like cool
and you can if it all falls in a heap
it doesn't matter because you've got
your money and your status and all of
your stability to fall back on and
everyone will just sort of think that
you're a bit bohemian whereas if you're
a working-class underclass woman who's
basically you know living polyamory like
having
lots of different partners and lots of
different children by them people one
will think you're trash but two
like your life becomes so challenging
because you've got
you've got all these children to look
after and you don't have the reliable
support of a partner
and like you're at risk of absolutely
everything falling apart
but but this is yeah it's it is a luxury
belief in the sense that saying that
that's a good thing and and and
resisting
the
um
resisting the traditional norms that
used to that used to exist
gives status to
rich people well think about i i really
like the idea that
um
beating the other side was more
important than raising up the people of
your political party and i think that
that's very true there was a study that
i saw around about 2012
surveys of uh democrats and republicans
the um proportions twisted and they
flipped from i vote for my party because
i like my party two i vote for my party
because i dislike the other party pretty
much
more people were doing protest votes
because of a hatred of the other rather
than a love of the similar
yeah
you go
how easily is that to be weaponized you
know and how many perverse incentives
are you going to create there
you mentioned at the beginning about um
how my book could be received in america
and
um
not all but a lot of
a lot of my friends who are also writing
on similar things like mary and nina and
so on are british
and
british feminism is much more it's much
more permissible to say this stuff than
it is in the states in general
and i think the reason for that is that
we don't really have a christian right
in the uk
so there isn't really any like fearsome
enemy that we all need to be focused
against and things like abortion rights
are
rock solid pretty much like not in
ireland but in the mainland uk
um
like that doesn't feel under threat and
i think that's what it is that because i
think american feminists are just so
focused all the time
on like often shadow boxing against the
christian right in the sense that i
think they overstate their influence and
their power and they're kind of stuck in
the past a little bit
and there's this like underdog mentality
that we
things like constantly having to
reassert like oh you shouldn't be a
change of sex you should be you know
it's like we've won that fight come on
like look at any any newspaper magazine
tv channel or whatever like
the idea that women are not allowed to
say they enjoy sex it's like 50 years
out of date come on so they're so
focused on
us like somewhat imaginary enemy
that they can't actually interrogate the
coherence of their own views whereas
they think in the uk that isn't that
isn't so much the case at all and
actually
there's a lot more
things like
trans politics or whatever which we
haven't gone into in in this discussion
but is
is much more cross-party is not there
isn't this like
really fierce dichotomy
politically which i think gives more
space for thinking critically i i feel
like i can write this book and i'm not
going to get pegged as
a crazy conservative
i might be wrong about that
we'll wait and see how should people act
then given all of this everything that
we've gone through how should people act
so i mean i i do basically make the case
in the book for for
being a bit more old-fashioned on some
stuff like i a lot of a lot of that
section of it is directed more women
than it meant so like i think for
instance it's a good idea for women not
to have sex on the first date
or not even to have sex in the first
three months
because that that gives you the
opportunity to assess whether or not he
considers you to be good time only
or if
your wife material
stuff like that which like you could
basically read in
most
agony arts from like the
1950s which is obviously what i get
accused of in my reviews um but also
they like there was there was a reason
for it it wasn't it wasn't motivated by
misogyny you know there was a there was
like a proper principle behind it um
i mean similarly for men i mean i don't
know what i don't know what advice i
have to offer in cells to be honest
i think i'm probably not the right
person to offer any kind of advice
because typically they don't like advice
in any case
from like
a fish teaching a fisherman how to fish
type thing
yeah it just it goes down badly i had
nama kates on um a couple of months ago
maybe six months ago and she's done tons
of work tons of research like firsthand
research into it
a lot of people were unhappy about the
fact that she wasn't someone that could
understand their plight um so okay so
for women don't have sex on the first
day not having sex for three months so
there's an interesting uh insight i
learned from jeffrey miller evolutionary
psychologist so his book mate that he
wrote with tucker max which should have
been so much bigger than it was it's
such a shame that it didn't do like
mental numbers because it's great
he explained about how um [ __ ] shaming
is
a
sort of game theoretic enforcement
mechanism to ensure that the price of
sex doesn't descend lower than women
wants it to which is why most women are
the enforcers of slut-shaming not men
men actually have an incentive for
slut-shaming to go away
but
one of the problems that you have here
is
you can kind of see ease of sex or or
speed towards um
uh being accepting of having sex with a
potential new partner as kind of being a
price right and as you start to extend
that out the price that the man has to
pay continues to go up and up and up so
you really do need a bit of a god's eye
view because if every woman tomorrow
said right no sex until three months
that's fine that's the playing field
maybe you'd have more men that would
sort of duck out of the dating game but
over time they would acclimatize right
because we acclimatized to no sex before
marriage
that was there so yeah yeah i think okay
so what else what else can people do
i mean yeah so on that point about um
yeah i mean strike breakers
for everyone else the
i think that
one of the things i hope comes from the
book
is that
a lot of young women in particular
because they've not yet learned through
life experience are phenomenally
ignorant about the reality of male
sexuality and the reality of sexual
difference
and so don't realize for instance some
of what we've spoken about the fact that
like
the sexual double standard is alive and
well
and
a lot of like men can have emotional sex
in a way that women can't and all of
this and so will interpret for instance
um
they will misinterpret a lot of male
behavior
and end up making decisions actually not
in their best interest because they they
think that you know the guy who wants to
sleep with them
must want something more from them
afterwards and then and then i like
you know learn the hard way that that's
not true
and i think that actually
if if there was more
knowledge widespread knowledge about
the existence of these facts
i think actually that young women's
behavior could change quite quickly
because at the moment for instance the
like you go on tick tock or whatever and
you get
young women will do things like show off
their bruises that they've got from
having rough sex with men who like
obviously hate them
but there is a status symbol because
it's a sign of being oh look i'm so
attractive and particularly things like
choking a lot of women interpret choking
as being a sign of like passionate love
like in like a 50 shades of grey away
like i want you so much i'll do anything
to have you is the way that this is like
interpreted in the romantic imagination
that's not generally how the men who are
doing it interpret it at all so there's
this like mutual miscomprehension where
each sex is doing something and they
actually don't like realize how the
other side is interpreting it i think if
more women realize that it would it
would no longer be high status to be
showing off your bruises on tick tock
because actually the like the truth of
it is that basically any moderately good
looking young woman can get as many
partners as she wants
and can get them to do
you know if she if if she asks them to
choke her they will
it's not a sign
of being super attractive
but it's misinterpreted
as being as such so i think that if
there were more
i think there was a better understanding
than some of the incentives would change
which would be a thing for young women
louise perry ladies and gentlemen i
really really enjoyed the book i think
that
the uh group of
women that we've got in the uk you marry
nina we need to come up with a new net
this can be a public service
announcement to the people that are
still listening um before we started we
came up with the name of based british
women but then realized that the acronym
of bbw can unfortunately be problematic
so if you've got an alternative that the
girls can use that would be great um but
yeah i think that it's really great i
really really like all of the work that
you guys have put out um
where should people go they want to read
more of your stuff online where should
they go
so there's a book obviously which is out
already in the uk the case against sex
revolution
um and it's out at the end of august in
america
and i write a weekly column for the new
statesman you've got a sub stack as well
right
no i don't actually i i started one very
briefly but then i got for the news
admin job and i can't do two columns in
one week so
take the money louise i appreciate you
thank you
thank you so much what's happening
people thank you very much for tuning in
if you enjoyed that episode then press
here for a selection of the best clips
from the podcast over the last few weeks
and don't forget to subscribe
peace